I want you to go back in time a little
bit and I want you to think about corner
geometry if you've given a line like
this but if you want to find out okay
that line has been inclined to the axis
what angle has it been implied that you
can use tree like we're in right now so
find out what that angle is
okay all you need to do to supply a
little bit of extra information is
choose trick you need a triangle
don't you love different triangles I can
put in that in fact I can put almost any
triangle in my life watch this if I drop
down a perpendicular line to the axis
from any point along the line okay you
can see what I created with my vertical
and my horizontal is a representation of
premium right because this is rise over
run so if we go ahead and label that
because I live in a right angle triangle
which trigonometric ratio connects rise
and run its tan Peter isn't it so we are
the gradient by definition is rise over
run but because it also measured a right
angle triangle that means that the
gradient is not just rise and run is ten
so this is not the new years old you see
this before okay so now we're going to
extend it and say you don't want the
angle with the axis but if you want the
angle between two lines that are offered
funny angles each of them like these two
how do you work that out but here's one
lastly this speed up here okay so to
help me work this out what I'm going to
do is compare this problem to the
problem that you just solved right there
at the point where two lines meet you
can imagine that will sort of panel so
this isn't it right it's like that's
where I'm measuring the angles so what
I'm going to add is a sort of horizontal
line in here parallel
because then I can measure using this
what the individual things are then they
combine to appear so watch this if i put
this horizontally across like that okay
if I give these lines to themes let's
call this guy over here by one and this
one one two
each one I can work out its angle
independently using this fact to work
out each layers gradient and then I can
chuck it into you okay so now I'll find
clue what the right politics is on if I
call this big angle here alpha and this
one only here beyond then what's an
expression so the angle I actually work
which is the octave it's just going to
be a big one take away the little one
like it's just the difference between
this so watch if I just say is 1 1 theta
I'm going to have to get to there
through 10 ok just like I did up here 10
theta is equal to by definition
Tanith alpha minus B that's what you
told me to compare right but now after
this boarding I have expensive business
right
what's our equation for the difference I
mean once when it comes to the box and
our photo - yup
and then or over one pot ok first looks
at the box full of season
okay now here's the lovely thing about
this right knowing that this is true can
alpha for instance 10 alpha is just the
grading of this line isn't it just like
can't deal with the gradient of that
line caviar is the gradient of the
shallow alone the second line proof so I
can write this all in terms of gradients
not in terms of cans at all it's going
to be one gradient I'm just giving it a
name based on the needs are good one
takeaway and other gradient on the
bottom I've got that okay does that make
sense do you see what I don't so now I
can go directly to is angle between two
lines so why don't I do the gradients
between or the gradients or rather go to
two lines okay let's just give a quick
example on these lines really flat let's
say I'm let's get an equation let's call
this one I'm like y equals 3x that's
pretty steep there to the origin go that
let's keep this one pretty simple it's
called like X plus X plus 2 something
like that because it doesn't start of
your article okay
what's the great image like
is three and one CS plus two what
difference does it makes when I'm
working at the angle between two mines
that plus two what difference is a meter
this via the answer is it actually
doesn't make a difference to size it
just went like if I move this light down
here it would still be the same
magnitude or just be in a different spot
I don't care about that I just care at
the size of you right so now watch what
happens if I just have a go as an event
work it might say candy you'll need your
calculator for this in a second by the
way phytate kid big R is equal to what's
on the top this is going to be three
take away 1 divided by 1 1 plus 3 times
1 which is 3 so that is not so on the
top by side 2 on the bottom I have orc
so apparently 10 feet are where theta is
the angle between two lines in the heart
now don't what Kathy don't feed on so
can you on your calculator you know what
this you're gonna have to go and ships
tanner then you're going to supply that
can give me sort of nearest degree funny
I think around us between seven others
approximately what do you think that
look like 27 degrees dollars right
checked out now this is not the only
angle between the two lines I have
measured this one the small one where
after you see that same theta by the way
where else do this it's vertically
opposite you recognize that this feed
here as well so those are the same but
then there's this other angle right
what's the other angle it's not a cute
it's obtuse right this is just like the
abuse case better sign rule if you
recall that right so if you're asked for
the obtuse angle you'll find this out
and then how do you get your cheese hang
glider
yeah you 110 degrees minus fact looking
for the supplement okay far in a way
what you're always asked for is the
acute angle so therefore it's really
easy we just slap absolute value signs
around anyone tell me why absolute value
signs give you the acute angle
you guys remember this do you remember
this don't you turn right if you are not
trying to confuse with this Constitution
and you see in a single is offering this
budget right with Terry's name so if you
restrict and you say actually I'm
explicitly going to say can has to be
positives they know the absolute they
done it locks you into the first
quadrant does that make sense so
therefore you will get me cute people
out of them even if you do instead of
three take away one if you do one take
away three all the numbers end up being
the same signs just Nikki now before we
leave this don't get you right this time
there's one little tricky after watch
out for this guy young m1 m2 you get
into a little bit of trouble with
fractions whenever your fractions have a
denominator 0 that makes things blow up
right what value of m1a2 would make the
denominator 0 this is 1 plus and wanted
to write
so if m1 m2 equals what Marlon's
negative 1 you're in trouble okay now
here's my question
what why is it that this causes trouble
for theaters can anyone fear if you have
two lines and you multiply their grades
you get negative 1 that means the two
graded are negative reciprocals type a
which is what happens for perpendicular
lines now that leaves the next questions
what's wrong with perpendicular lines
what does please thing got to do with
perpendicular lines
ah yes so if the angle between two lines
is 93 you're trouble because can 90 land
you on an asymptote doesn't it because
cloud 90 years year ago define okay so
because this depends on can like
obviously lines can be perpendicular but
this is not going to find it for you
maybe you're going to have to walk
you're gonna have to recognize your
greens and not look through this you're
just going to take this perpendicular
therefore the air go to into mind there
is no degrees and you . go please don't
really use this high-tech machinery okay
so why don't you get that down you can
draw these diagrams they're very very
important and then have this across on
the side here this is what you want to
put near 90 deep bonds along with the
warning that if your lines are
perpendicular then don't go to orders
effort to find some special angle just
notice if open dick Euler so the angle
between two lines kids nine okay